peter schiff the famous bitcoin skeptic
he recently had his puerto rican bank
shut down what am i talking about well
peter came out and he tweeted despite no
evidence of crimes puerto rico
regulators closed my bank anyway for net
capital issues rather than allow a sale
to a highly qualified buyer promising to
inject capital far in excess of
regulatory minimums as a result accounts
are frozen and customers may lose money
now i have no clue what's going on here
i'm not privy to any more details than
you are by simply reading his tweets but
what i do know is that peter schiff the
skeptic of bitcoin is getting a
first-hand lesson on how bitcoin fixes
this now bitcoin fixes this as a meme
that's become more and more popular over
time but in this case it quite literally
fixes this the whole idea of bitcoin is
that it returns sovereignty to the
individual holders if you are an
individual who wants to have economic
value protected and make sure that
you're always in control bitcoin gives
you that ability now if you go and you
put deposits in a traditional bank of
course it's not your money anymore the
second you make a deposit it's now the
bank's money they can lend it out and do
whatever they want with it and yes they
do owe it back to you but just because
they owe it to you doesn't mean you'll
naturally get it and peter schiff in
this situation in puerto rico is proving
exactly that now i don't necessarily
think that people are gonna go take a
hundred percent of their net worth and
go put it in bitcoin actually i think
that that'd be kind of crazy right now
instead what i think most people are
starting to realize is that bitcoin and
its self-sovereignty allows for a
certain portion of their net worth or
their portfolio to give them aspects of
control that they don't have in the
legacy financial system peter schiff as
the bitcoin skeptic getting this crash
course you never want to wish bad things
on anyone
but i think that we're getting a lesson
right here the bitcoin and its
self-sovereignty is very very powerful
now i wish peter the best i think that
he'll figure something out
but it's always important to realize
that whether we are talking about the
western developed world or we are
talking about people in areas of
conflict like ukraine or in countries
and societies that are failing like
venezuela or zimbabwe there are many
people around the world by some
estimations millions if not billions
that are understanding the power of
bitcoin and the importance of
self-sovereignty it used to be that you
had physical cash and when you had your
physical cash you were in control of it
now bitcoin is ushering in a new era of
that sovereignty in a digital form
and it takes a while for people around
the world to understand how the
technology works and to realize why it's
so valuable
but as we're seeing here
even if you're using a bank in the
western developed nation there can still
be plenty of issues and so ultimately
bitcoin self-sovereignty and the
importance of self-custody
sits center stage in this saga i wish
peter the best and bitcoin fixes this
hey you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time